my mom's dating this guy and then he
dumped her out of the blue and started
dating a woman who lived directly across
the street and she was crying looking
out the window like waiting to see if
this guy who just broke her heart was
like walking into his like new
girlfriend's house I was teenager so
like my dad was coming over to take me
to baseball practice he goes hey stupid
your mother's out there crying I said
yeah he goes you know what it's about I
was like you know the guy John she was
Da and he goes yeah I know that [__]
and I that's he said like he just hated
all my boyfriends he goes well he dumped
her and he's dating a woman who lives
across the street and my dad goes are
you going to do something about
that and I go what do you want me to do
about it he goes I'm going to be right
back and I hear my mother screaming Tony
stop stop it right now you're going to
kill him stop it and then I run
downstairs my dad had rang the bell
waited for this guy to come downstairs
dragged him outside and started beating
the [__] out of him and my dad he goes
that was your job to me I was like what
what and then he goes just going